>> Sean: HE WILL BE HERE AT
SUNDAY NIGHT AT 9 P.M.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
DAMNING NEW DETAILS ABOUT JOE
BIDEN’S FAMILY CORRUPTION
SCANDALS.
IT PAINTS A VERY UGLY PICTURE.
BIDEN’S SON ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER, HIS BROTHER JIM, RECEIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM SKETCHY
FOREIGN NATIONALS CASHING IN ON
THEN VICE-PRESIDENT BIDEN.
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH AND THE BANK OF
CHINA.
THEY WERE MAKING MONEY.
NOW THANKS TO CONTROVERSY OF NEW
EVIDENCE IT’S INCREASINGLY CLEAR
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF PLAYED
A CRITICAL ROLE IN THE SKETCHY
PAYOUTS.
OFFERING SPECIAL ACCESS AND
EXCHANGE FOR SWEETHEART BUSINESS
DEALS.
MILLIONS FOR HIS FAMILY.
ACCORDING TO A FORMER BIDEN
BUSINESS PARTNER, TONY
BOBULINKSI, JOE BIDEN NOT ONLY
INTERVIEW INTEREST THE PAY FOR
PLAY SCHEMES WAS PART OF THE
PROCESS.
SO FAR NO ONE HAS REFUTED
BOBULINKSI’S CLAIM.
NOT JOE BIDEN, HUNTER BIDEN, NOT
JIM BIDEN.
AT FOX NEWS.COM, THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN JIM BIDEN WAS
ASKED IF HE HAD ANY RESPONSE TO
ALL OF THE CORRUPTION
ALLEGATIONS LEVELED AGAINST HIM
AND HIS FAMILY.
>> MR. BIDEN, DO YOU CARE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS?
>> NOPE.
>> WHY DID YOU INVOLVE JOE BIDEN
IN YOUR CHINA DEAL?
WHY DID YOU AND HUNTER BIDEN
WANT JOE BIDEN TO BE WITH TONY
B?
ARE YOU MR. JIM BIDEN?
I WANT TO ASK BUT THE CHINA
DEAL.
>> COULD YOU PLEASE STOP
BOTHERING ME?
YOU DON’T WANT TO COMMENT SIR, I
DON’T WANT TO COMMENT ABOUT
ANYTHING.
>> Sean: IT’S A SERIOUS SCANDAL.
NATIONAL SECURITY AND DIPLOMAT
IMPLICATIONS.
YOU WOULD NOT KNOW IT FROM CNN.
THEY DIDN’T COVER TUCKER’S HOUR
LONG INTERVIEW WITH
MR. BOBULINKSI.
THEY ARE NOT INVESTIGATING THE
CLAIMS OR VERIFYING THE
EVIDENCE.
-- THEY ARE IGNORING ALL OF IT
WHICH IS A SCANDAL.
AS THEY IGNORED THE JOHNSON AND
THE GRASSLEY REPORT AMPULLATE
-- ABOUT THE OLIGARCHS AND
CHINA.
IT’S LIKE A CENSORSHIP OF ALL OF
THIS BY BIG TECH COMPANIES,
TWITTER, FACEBOOK, THE MEDIA MOB
AND TONIGHT IT’S MORE OBVIOUS
THAN EVER THAT VERY POWERFUL
FORCES, BIG TECH COMPANIES
ALMOST ALL OF THEM.
THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY,
THE ESTABLISHMENT NEVER
TRUMPERS, WEAK ESTABLISHMENT
REPUBLICANS AND THE DEEP STATE
NOW ARE ALL ALIGNED AGAINST THIS
PRESIDENT AND HIS REELECTION.
THE ONLY THING THAT CAN STOP
THAT FROM HAPPENING IS YOU.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WITH AT LEAST 12 BATTLEGROUND
STATES IN PLAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TAKING
NOTHING AND NOBODY FOR GRANTED.
THE PRESIDENT IS TRAVELING THE
COUNTRY AT A RAPID PACE.
EARLY TODAY TWO RALLIES IN
ARIZONA.
TOMORROW IN FLORIDA AND NORTH
CAROLINA.
IN 6 DAYS, ONE THING NOBODY IS
TELLING YOU:
ANYBODY OUT THERE MAKING
PREDICTIONS THEY DON’T KNOW WHAT
THE HELL THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT.
NOBODY HAS A CRYSTAL BALL.
AND DON’T BELIEVE ANYONE THAT IS
TELLING YOU THEY KNOW HOW THIS
ELECTION WILL TURNOUT.
OR DONALD TRUMP ONLY HAS A 5%
CHANCE.
THAT’S AN EFFORT TO DEFLATE
CONSERVATIVE AND REPUBLICAN
VOTES.
YOUR VOTE IS CRITICAL.
EVERYBODY TAKES IT SERIOUSLY.
YES, YOU CAN SHOCK THE WORLD
AGAIN AND THE MEDIA MOB WILL
HAVE TO CHOKE ON THE WORDS WE
CAN PROJECT THAT DONALD TRUMP
HAS BEEN REELECTED THE 45th
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT CAN HAPPEN.
THAT IS YOUR POWER.
YOU GET TO DECIDE.
YOU ARE THE ULTIMATE JURY.
AND YOU ARE THE ONLY THING THAT
IS STANDING IN THE WAY OF THE
SINGLE MOST RADICAL EXTREME
SOCIALIST AGENDA AND WHAT WOULD
BE IN AN ADMINISTRATION IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
JOE BIDEN MAY BE AT THE TOP OF
THE DEMOCRATIC TICKET, BUT HE IS
NOT STEERING THE SHIP.
HE IS WEAK AND FRAIL.
HE IS STRUGGLING.
HE CAN BARELY GET HIS WORDS
TOGETHER.
HE SEEMS AT TIMES COMPLETELY OUT
OF AND BEING MANIPULATED BY THE
RADICALS IN CHARGE.
TODAY WAS A BIG DAY FOR JOE
BIDEN.
THIS MORNING DRIVEN TO A LOCAL
POLLING SIGHT NEAR HIS HOME IN
DELAWARE WHERE HE VOTED EARLY
AND DELIVERED A COUPLE OF
REMARKS AND SPENT THE REST OF
THE AFTERNOON IN HIS BASEMENT
BUNKER.
6 DAYS UNTIL AN ALL IMPORTANT
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
JOE BIDEN TOOK THE DAY OFF
AGAIN.
NOT HOLDING RALLIES.
NOT VISITING BATTLEGROUND
STATES.
BARACK OBAMA IS DOING MORE
CAMPAIGNING FOR JOE BIDEN THAN
JOE BIDEN IS.
YOU HAVE KAMALA HARRIS.
SHE WAS OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL RARELY FOR HER TOO.
TODAY WHEN HE WAS TAKING A NAP
IN DELAWARE, SHE WAS IN THE
STATE OF ARIZONA HOSTING A FEW
EVENTS WITH TINY LITTLE BABY
CROWDS.
VERY FEW PEOPLE.
AT THIS POINT EVEN JOE BIDEN IS
STATING THE OBVIOUS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MY NAME IS JOE BIDEN AND I AM
JILL BIDEN’S HUSBAND AND I AM
KAMALA’S RUNNING MATE.
[LAUGHING]
Y’ALL THINK I AM KIDDING, DON’T
YOU?
>> Sean: WHEN THEY TELL YOU WHO
THEY ARE, BELIEVE THEM.
SENATOR HARRIS IS IN CHARGE.
HER RECORD IS TO THE LEFT OF
BERNIE SANDERS.
ACCORDING TO THE NON-PARTISAN
STUDY RANKED THE MOST LIBERAL
SENATOR IN 2019 TO THE LEFT OF
BERNIE SANDERS A DEVOUT
SOCIALIST AND CO-SPONSORED THE
GREEN NEW DEAL AND WANTS TO STOP
FRACKING AND LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
RED MEAT AMERICANS ARE ALLOWED
TO CONSUME.
IN FAVOR OF MEDICARE FOR ALL AND
TAXPAYER FUNDED HEALTH INSURANCE
FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
HE IS AGAINST PRIVATE HEALTHCARE
PLANS AND SUPPORTS PACKING THE
COURT.
PROMISED TO CONFISCATE GUNS.
THESE ARE RADICAL BELIEFS OUT OF
THE MAINSTREAM.
THAT’S THE NEW DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY.
PAY ATTENTION.
IF SOME OF THE POLLS ARE RIGHT,
MOST PEOPLE DON’T THINK JOE
BIDEN COULD FINISH A FIRST TIME.
WATCH KAMALA.
JOE BIDEN’S OWN WEBSITE PRAISES
THE GREEN NEW DEAL TO BATTLE
CLIMATE AVERAGE.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ SAID
THIS ABOUT THE RADICAL
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> DESPITE BILLION DOLLARS OF
FOSSILE FUEL MONEY AND LOBBYING
AND MEDIA CAMPAIGNS TO SMEAR THE
GREEN NEW DEAL, A MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE STILL BELIEVE IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT THE GREEN NEW DEAL
IS THE RIGHT WAY FORWARD.
>> Sean: THE MAIN GOAL OF THE
GREEN NEW DEAL IS TO PUT THE OIL
AND THE GAS INDUSTRY, ENERGY
INDUSTRY, OUT OF BUSINESS.
THAT MEANS MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF HIGH PAYING CAREER JOBS IN
THE ENERGY SECTOR WILL BE
ELIMINATED.
OUR ECONOMY WILL BE DEVASTATEED
IN PLACES LIKE PENNSYLVANIA AND
OHIO AND NEW MEXICO AND OKLAHOMA
AND TEXAS.
TO ACCOMPLISH IT RADICAL AGENDA,
DEMOCRATS COULD NEED TO SEIZE
CONTROL OF THE U.S. SUPREME
COURT.
DURING THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY
EVEN KAMALA HARRIS SAID THAT THE
DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE WILLING TO
PACK THE COURTS.
THAT WOULD BE THE BIGGEST POWER
GRAB IN 150 YEARS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
MULTIPLE HIGH-PROFILE DEMOCRATS
ARE THREATENING TO DO THAT
INCLUDING RON EMANUEL.
>> SCHUMER SAID REPUBLICANS WILL
REGRET HER CONFIRMATION.
DO YOU THINK THEY WILL?
>> YES, I THINK THE REPUBLICANS
WILL REGRET NOT ONLY WHAT THEY
DID HERE BUT ALSO TO GARLAND AT
THE END OF 2016.
THEY TWICE HAVE NOW BENT THE
RULES AND CRACKED THEM AND
BROKEN THEM TO SEIZE POWER IN
THE SUPREME COURT.
>> Sean: HE IS LYING AS USUAL.
29 PRESIDENTS MADE A NOMINATION
TO THE SUPREME COURT.
YOU WOULD BE HARD PRESSED TO
FIND ANY DEMOCRAT WHO IS NOT
THREATENING TO THE PACK THE
COURTS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE NEXT TIME THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE GIVE DEMOCRATS A MAJORITY
IN THIS CHAMBER, YOU WILL HAVE
FORFEITED THE RIGHT TO TELL US
HOW TO RUN THAT MAJORITY.
MY COLLEAGUES MAY REGRET THIS
FOR A LOT LONGER THAN THEY
THINK.
>> HOW DO WE REBALANCE OUR
COURTS?
THE TWO SUPREME COURT CASES THAT
HAVE BEEN STOLEN WHERE PROCESSES
HAVE JAMMED THROUGH PARTISAN
NOMINEES.
>> SHOULD WE EXPAND THE COURT?
WELL, LET’S TAKE A LOOK AND SEE.
THAT MEANS MAYBE WE NEED MORE
DISTRICT COURTS AS WELL.
>> Sean: THIS ELECTION MATTERS.
BELIEVE THEM.
DEMOCRATS WILL PACK THE COURT SO
THEIR RADICAL AGENDA WILL BE
UNCHECKED.
THERE WILL BE NOTHING TO STOP
THEM FROM STRIPPING AWAY YOUR
RIGHTS AND NATIONALIZING MAJOR
SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY, TAKING
PRIVATE PROPERTY AND ELIMINATING
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
AND JOE AND KAMALA THERE WOULD
BE AMNESTY FOR MILLIONS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THEY ARE TELLING YOU
THIS, WILL BE FORCED TO PAY FOR
THE HEALTH INSURANCE AND OTHER